a lot of people seem to be using this
tragedy to beat the drums of war and
feed the military industrial complex do
you worry about
this the people who
are rooting for escalation and how can
it be stopped one of the things that
does concern me is that there are very
few people alive today who actually
viscerally understand the horrors of War
at least in the US I mean obviously the
people in on the front lines in Ukraine
and Russia who understand just how
terrible war is um but how many people
in the west understand it um you know my
grandfather was in World War II uh he
was severely traumatized um I mean he
was there I think in for almost six
years in the in East North Africa in
Italy uh all his friends were killed uh
in front of him and uh he would have
died too um except they randomly gave
some I guess IQ test or something and uh
he scored very high um now he was not an
officer he was a I think a Corporal or a
sergeant or something like that um
because he didn't finish High School um
he had to drop out of high school
because his his his dad died and he had
to work to support his um siblings um so
because he didn't graduate high school
he was not eligible for the officer
Corp um so you know he kind of got put
into the cannon fighter category
basically um but then randomly that gave
him this test he was transferred to
British intelligence in London that's
where he met my grandmother um but uh he
he had PTSD next level like next level I
mean just didn't talk just didn't talk
and if you tried talking to him he'd
just tell you to shut up and he woron a
bunch of medals never never ragged about
it once not not even they hinted nothing
I like found out about it because I his
military records were online that's a
how I know so he would say like no no no
way in hell do you want to do you want
to do that again but how many people um
now he he obviously he died you know 20
years ago well longer actually 30 years
ago
um how many people are alive that
remember World War II not many and the
same perhaps applies to the threat of
nuclear
war yeah I mean there are enough nuclear
bombs pointed at uh United States to
make the rubel the radioactive rubel
bounce many times
there's two major Wars going on right
now so you talked about the threat of
AGI quite a bit but now as we sit here
with the intensity of conflict going on
do you worry about nuclear
war I think we shouldn't discount the
possibility of nuclear war um it is a
civilizational
threat
um right now I could be wrong but I
think think the the current probability
of nuclear war is quite low um but there
are a lot of nukes pointed at us so and
we have a lot of nukes pointed at other
people they're still there nobody's put
their uh their guns
away the missiles are still in the silos
and uh the leaders don't seem to be the
ones with the nukes talking to each
other no there are Wars which are tragic
and difficult on a on a local basis and
then there are Wars which are
civilization ending or has that
potential obviously global thermonuclear
Warfare has high potential to end
civilization perhaps permanently but
certainly you know to
severely uh wound and and perhaps
uh set back uh human progress by you
know to the Stone Age or something I
don't know pretty
bad
um
probably scientists and Engineers won't
be super popular after that as well
they're like you got to S this
mess
so generally we I think we we obviously
want to prioritize civilizational risks
over things that are um painful and
tragic on on a local level but not
civilizational